bonjour mona vous êtes devant l'elysée
qu'attendre on va pas faire de la
politique fiction évidemment mais
qu'attendre de ce conseil de défense
mais bonjour magali et bien plusieurs
choses à attendre et ces derniers jours
ce l'exécutif n'a pas été très rassurant
jean castex le premier ministre a évoqué
l'hypothèse d'une troisième vague alors
ce conseil de défense sanitaire sera
l'occasion pour le gouvernement est bien
de faire le point sur la situation alors
que les hôpitaux sont saturés presque
sous tension et que l ile de france a
dépassé les 400 cas pour 100000
habitants et puis il ya aussi
l'apparition de ce fameux variant breton
qui va peut-être changer la donne alors
vous l'avez dit le point le plus
important va être s'il faut confiné ou
pas l'ile-de-france le premier ministre
jean castex ne s'en est pas caché ces
derniers jours la situation est
préoccupante en ile-de-france est à vrai
dire les depuis plusieurs jours déjà
alors si le gouvernement a tenté de
retarder l'échéance et bien l'hypothèse
d'un confinement se dessine peu à peu
c'est ce qu'a laissé entendre hier aussi
à jean castex chez nos confrères je cite
le moment est venu d'envisager est des
dispositions pour la région parisienne
et puis président de la république de
son côté a prévu lundi il faudra
appliquer des restrictions adaptée et
proportionnée à chaque territoire alors
mona il ya aussi la polémique autour du
vaccin astrazeneca ce qu'on peut
craindre un ralentissement de la
campagne vaccinale
et bien c'est très probable puisque
président de la république vous l'avez
dit a suspendu l'utilisation du vaccin à
strazeele et qui comme d'autres pays
après plusieurs polémiques autour de ce
vaccin au total presque quinze pays ont
suspendu alors la question et qu'il faut
se poser c'est est ce que la france va
finalement tenir ses engagements c'est
assez difficile à dire il va falloir
attendre la décision du régulateur
européen si la vie est positif et bien
la campagne de vaccination va poursuivre
son cours
en revanche si la vie est négatif et
bien cela va considérablement ralentir à
la vaccination en france puisque vous
savez le gouvernement a commandé des
millions de doses de ce vaccin
astrazeneca et puis le gouvernement
s'est fixé est tout de même un ambitieux
objectif 30 millions de personnes
devraient être vaccinées d'ici le mois
de juin et ça c'est si tout marche bien
merci beaucoup
mona pour toutes ces précisions mena en
direct devant l'elysée